this week
on brian ross investigates the china
initiative
more than 10 american academics arrested
by the fbi
for taking secret payments from china it
has become much too commonplace
that the ruling communist party of china
thinks it can conduct illegal activity
and bend people here in the united
states
to its will in order to try and surpass
our country
as the world's leading superpower amid
growing concern about china's efforts
to steal the latest in american
innovation and technology
does china target academics as a way to
get into the uh
the guts and the brains of the united
states absolutely
pushback from academics over the latest
charges against a prominent professor
at mit has the fbi gone too far
so in the end a very real concern about
chinese
economic military espionage could be
damaged if there is an overreach
absolutely plus vaccine mania
what to do about those people prepared
to lie cheat
and throw around their money to cut in
line for a coveted 19 vaccination
mounting frustration across the country
now causing suspicion over special
treatment
and so-called vaccine tourism vaccines
intended for texans
are ending up in the arms of people from
other countries
we're joined by the former acting
surgeon general dr boris lushniak
of the university of maryland school of
public health
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the editors of
mediaite on their choices for who got it
right
who got it wrong from the law and crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague at law and crime
rhonda schwartz and ronda we begin with
the china
initiative a now highly controversial
effort begun under the trump
administration
to crack down on efforts by china to
essentially steal u.s technology
using military and economic espionage
rhonda
and there's been a sharp focus on
professors and scientists
at some prominent universities including
ivy league universities accused of
secretly taking payments from china
and now some say that this whole effort
by the department of justice and the fbi
has just gone too far brian
a distinguished professor at mit at
cambridge massachusetts
is the latest target of the government's
china initiative
56 year old gang chen the chair of the
school's mechanical engineering
department
and a naturalized u.s citizen was
arrested by the fbi in the last days
of the trump administration the u.s
attorney in boston said
the case involved tens of millions of
dollars in payments
and that chen was charged with wire
fraud making false statements
and failing to disclose a bank account
in china on his tax returns
based on the complaint chen not only hid
the extent of his own affiliations
with the chinese government but actively
worked to further the goals
of the chinese while employed
by the massachusetts institute of
technology
chen is now the latest of at least 10
american academics to be charged
in connection with the china initiative
a harvard scientist is among three
people
charged with lying about their
affiliation with china
last year a leading scientist at harvard
university
charles lieber was also charged with
hiding payments he had taken from the
chinese
he has pleaded not guilty and has been
suspended by harvard
it has become much too commonplace that
the ruling
communist party of china thinks it can
conduct
illegal activity and bend people here in
the united states
to its will in order to try and surpass
our country as the world's leading
superpower
u.s intelligence agents say they are
trying to crack down
on an increasingly aggressive espionage
effort by beijing
aimed at stealing u.s technology this is
the justice department's effort to
really try to
root out uh contacts that have been in
place or
something in combination with the fbi to
really kind of get their arms around
to the extent to which china is
collecting in the u.s either for
espionage purposes or just state
collection
and does china target academics as a way
to get into the uh
the guts and the brains of the united
states absolutely
and so you you see a real espionage
threat then
i do i do but mit is standing behind his
professor
paying the legal fees for professor chet
maintaining
that his joint efforts with the chinese
scientists were part of his job
at no secret some are calling the u.s
effort
an overreach certainly as the us china
relationship has shifted dramatically in
recent years
uh research partnerships and engagements
that uh scientifically that were once
regarded as relatively innocuous are now
being being regarded in retrospect with
new levels of concern and suspicions so
in the end uh a very real concern about
chinese
economic and military espionage could be
damaged if there is an overreach
absolutely we're joined now by john c
yang who is the president and executive
director of the group
asian americans advancing justice mr
yang thank you so much for being here
this evening
thank you very much for having me
what do you make of these cases
involving the mit professor and other
cases around the country
that seem to target predominantly
chinese american professors
unfortunately what we see seems to be
another form of racial profiling
and this is something unfortunately that
we've seen throughout history that
asian americans are targeted for
national security threats
in a way that is really a form of
profiling
and we could go back to whether it is 9
11
after the terrorist attacks on the world
trade center the pentagon
and congress go back to world war ii
with the incarceration of japanese
americans and i emphasize
americans on so-called national security
grounds
or you even go back to the late 1800s
when we enacted the chinese exclusion
law because of this notion that chinese
were somehow taking away
american jobs here in the united states
so we see this for asian american
community as part and parcel of that
with the pushback now against the
charges brought against
the professor at mit do you see this
policy changing under the biden
administration
well we are hopeful that the buying
administration will take a fresh hard
look at this
look i do not want to say that the
chinese
government is innocent certainly we know
that the chinese government
engages in espionage but we also know
that this china
initiative has put great pressure on doj
to really meet quotas uh this national
security division
assistant attorney general said that doj
should bring a case in every single u.s
attorney's jurisdiction
on the china initiative and we know that
that's ludicrous
the fact of the matter is we need to
focus on what is real
and not try to create these trumped-up
charges and many of these charges that
we have seen
under the china initiative frankly are
not charges for economic espionage
but for cases of simple administrative
oversight
places of failure to disclose certain
forms or bank accounts
and things that could be handled at a
much different level than these criminal
complaints
or these notions that this is about
about espionage
mr yang a question for you from our
executive producer rhonda schwartz
rhonda
as you said you don't really disavow the
notion that china has had a tradition
of trying of economic espionage
so what what is the right solution here
what
what should be the next steps from this
administration or national security
uh concerns in this country well
certainly we think we should put a halt
to the so-called china initiative this
notion if we
of targeting a specific group of people
based on espionage concerns without
really looking at the facts
doesn't seem to make sense so what we
are asking for is a pause on the china
initiative to stop the china initiative
and let's review the cases that have
been brought see if there are cases that
involve racial profiling
are cases that involve overreach and
then develop
a really more of a systemic approach an
individualized approach we all know that
there's espionage that takes place
all around the world and to focus in
this way on
a particular population is overblown
but you don't deny do you mr yang that
there have been some efforts targeted
at chinese-american academics
well look the fact of the matter is if
you look at
any foreign government those governments
are seeking to steal american secrets
again i we don't want to in any way
say that that is not happening but again
to suggest somehow that as a result
we should be targeting targeting chinese
americans
or targeting americans that have any
sort of connection with china
which is what we are seeing in some of
these criminal complaints really does
not make sense
and what is the impact you think when
these allegations are made against
very prominent and distinguished
professors
well the flip side to this is is this
really
really helping our national security one
of the things about the united states is
that we have welcomed scientists we have
welcomed academics
and that has contributed to our
innovation that has contributed to our
scientific knowledge
and what is happening now is scientists
academics professors
students are afraid to come to this
country because of this perception that
our country has become xenophobic
our country has become fearful of
foreigners
and that really causes our country to
suffer because of it
so again what we are looking at is how
do we make sure that our country
continues to prosper
continues to develop and part of that is
making sure that we are a welcoming
country
john c yang of asian americans advancing
justice thank you so much for joining us
to see
thank you very much coming up next
vaccine mania all the shenanigans
dishonesty deceit
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime
trial now
back now with vaccine mania all eyes in
this country watching the bite
administration
trying to speed up delivery of the
coveted 19 vaccine
amid efforts by some to try to cut in
line
and others to try to buy their way to
the head of the line
mounting frustration across the country
now causing suspicion over special
treatment
and so-called vaccine tourism it's been
headline news in the u.s
growing anger over non-residents like
canadian snowbirds
getting the vaccine in florida where
anyone over age 65
is eligible one doctor we spoke with in
mexico city says he knows of at least
10 cases telling us patients have been
vaccinated in various u.s cities
dr joseph varone of united memorial
medical center says vaccines
intended for texans are ending up in the
arms of people from other countries
i get text messages every five minutes
of people from all over the world hey
can you
can you set us up with a vaccine as most
americans wait to get the covert vaccine
we are learning about
accusations that some wealthy and
well-connected people are trying to cut
the line now media reports say the morse
life health system
they run a nursing home in west palm
beach they vaccinated wealthy
board members their friends and members
of the palm beach country club
instead of all of its elderly residents
and staff
and so we're joined now by dr boris
lesniak he is the head of the school of
public health at the university of
maryland former acting
surgeon general the united states dr
lushniak uh
thanks for coming back on the show what
do you make of all these efforts to cut
in line
well you know this is a reflection of
how difficult it is to do what we're
trying to do right now don't forget our
goal
ultimately is to get what the term that
we're using is herd immunity population
immunity
which means at some point to be
successful we got to get 80 percent of
our population back
uh we've not done this in modern times
before right this level of having an
immunization program
and we're definitely going through our
growing pains right now and the groin
pains
are surrounded by the issues of what a
lack of supply of these vaccines and
then
lack of an infrastructure to do this
well so we're seeing a reflection of all
this
right now and the desperation in some
people to try to get to the front of the
line to try to buy into this
the reality of the situation is from a
medical perspective we have higher risk
individuals who absolutely need to have
the vaccine
anybody who gets in ahead of these
individuals is really doing
a wrong against those people so we got
to get better at controlling
the flow of individuals getting vaccine
dr lushnik is one of the country's
leading experts on public health you
were critical of the trump
administration
what's your report card so far on the
bide administration efforts well
it's early on in this administration
obviously there has been a shift
and the shift is guess what the
scientists are speaking more
loudly now right we see dr fauci playing
a key role out of the white house and
being a key spokesperson
the politicians have in essence backed
off a little bit right we're not seeing
the president speaking about this every
day and i believe that's a good thing
let's get information from the expert
regarding the vaccination program once
again
this is something that's not been done
the goal is
ultimately to get more than a million
people vaccinated every day i think the
last few days we've been getting roughly
1.3 million people vaccinated
to do this right we're talking about
ultimately getting two or three million
people vaccinated each and every day
so there's a long road ahead of us to
get this right
indeed dr lakshnayak a question for you
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
what about these new strains of the
virus that are being detected and
it will the vaccine be effective against
this is there a new threat emerging
that's a great question rhonda and the
real answer to that is
we don't know i mean the best we can do
is look at the vaccines that are
currently available and
as the new strains right these mutations
start spreading in our communities
to be able to look at how effective
those vaccines are against
preliminary information says you know
specifically the south african strain
is of concern right it's still better
than nothing it's still
greater than 50 effectiveness but it's
certainly not at the 90 percent
you know to a large extent we're going
to have to let science take the course
and data provide information to the
scientists
right we're already talking about the
idea of perhaps at some point needing
boosters or needing modifications of the
current vaccine to be able to cover
these mutations
time will tell
as you know dr lushnik some experts some
of your uh colleagues are suggesting
only one shot not two shots
to make sure more people get at least
one shot does that make sense to you
well you know we what do we know
everything should be data driven right
and what we know is certainly from the
initial
vaccines that have been uh approved
under emergency use
authorization that there is an
effectiveness from these vaccines
after one dose it's not as good as after
two doses
therefore i mean there's a major
consideration from a regulatory
perspective
right will fda okay the use of just one
shop right the emergency use
authorization really said it's a two
shot routine
so it really sort of boils down to this
idea of coverage of
larger numbers of our population versus
getting those individuals fully covered
that need to get covered
there's no right or wrong right now on
this i would prefer for us to work on
the idea
of a supply issue right the idea that we
have the pfizer
vaccine that needs to be ramped up
further that we have the modernizing
that we hope
soon to have the johnson johnson vaccine
the more that we have on this the less
we'll have to sort of cut the corners
regarding the data that's been presented
to the fda
so in short uh certainly a consideration
that we
go through a one sharp regimen right now
i'm just concerned as do we have the
information to say how long can we wait
for that section
and that information is being gathered
so i'm data driven
all right dr boris laschniac thank you
again for joining us this evening
always a pleasure thanks thank you very
much dr boris lesniak of the school of
public health at the university of
maryland
up next i'm brian ross investigates
winners and losers in the media
the remarkable story inside the last
days of the trump administration in the
oval office a slap down for general
flint
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of media and
we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who is the editor-in-chief of media
which like the law and crime trial
network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
and aiden we begin with your first
winner the
website axios with a remarkable story
behind the scenes
inside the oval office in the last days
of the trump administration
that's right so axios has been doing
series uh a reported series led by judd
their reporter jonathan swan and zachary
basu
which has taken a look at what happened
from the white house after
the election and the sort of quest to
overturn the results
and their latest is really astonishing
report uh
in which details an oval office meeting
between trump and a team of outside
advisors
which includes sydney powell a former
trump national security adviser
mike flynn and for some reason the
overstock ceo david byrne
um who has become sort of a uh one of
the proponents of this idea that the
election was stolen
they met with trump in the white house
and a team of actual white house legal
advisers and had this huge clash
uh over what the president could do to
undo the results of the election
um cindy powell was proposing things
like you know seizing voting machines
based on her claim that voting systems
company dominion was used to turn votes
from uh joe biden from donald trump to
joe biden um it's
all obviously all this stuff was crazy
conspiracy theories and the white house
advisors and lawyers according to this
axios report pushed back on it hard
um but it was really fascinating look
into what was happening in the white
house
in the last in its final days and the
extent to which the
trump was entertaining the idea of
taking drastic action to undo the
election
remarkable sourcing inside with the slap
down of the general flynn
sit your ass down exactly great great
reporting
the loser this week fox and friends for
trying to push a story
that nbc was trying to essentially cover
up for governor cuomo telling guests
not to use his name and criticize him
here's that clip
is the media covering for new york
governor andrew cuomo questions raised
after a woman whose mother died in a new
york nursing home last
april says nbc news told her to change
her words during an interview on the
state's crisis
so that's certainly a provocative
question what about it dayton
that's right so dawn best who very sadly
lost her mother uh in
a new york nursing home and has been
heavily critical of
andrew cuomo she appeared on nbc nightly
news for an interview
and she criticized andrew cuomo for the
decision to move covent patients into
nursing homes at the beginning of the
pandemic
now she's claiming on fox news that nbc
told her that she could not criticize
andrew cuomo
directly and actually asked her to
reword and answer to one of their
questions
and blame new york more broadly for
their government's response to the
pandemic
and sort of basically cover up for
andrew cuomo now that obviously sounded
odd to me just listening to it because
the idea that an nbc reporter would tell
a subject to sort of
cover for andrew seems a little we
got the actual footage of that raw
interview from a source at nbc
and reviewed it and it revealed that the
reporter never actually asked
this woman to change her uh comments and
to to
not mention andrew cuomo um so it was a
sort of odd
story we ended up back checking it and
uh and fox news has not
so far commented on it so i think
they're just moving on from from that
claim which does appear to have been
false
they've pushed out all kinds of strange
stories over the last
four years yeah
i think there's been an odd sort of uh
descent into
the more opinion based sort of culture
war topics at fox news and
and you can see that by the way that
they've shrunk their newsroom
um and expanded the the uh air time of
the union shows especially in prime time
um i think it's at the detriment of news
and that's what happens when you have
movements like that
for sure aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much for joining us and thanks to all of
you for
tuning in tonight to watch us we'll be
back again next week
and thanks to the great staff here at
long crime for guinea's on the air
and off the air without a hitch
[Music]
i